[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je croyais mater mais jusqu'à la nuit
des temps je croyais que nos amours ou à
grenoble 1 je me rappelle comme jour où
j'ai connu mon amour était mort qui tue
est venu j'avais position ouvrez vous
assumez les
que joue pas
mais toi tu étais là déjà comme un sale
état a besoin de moi on aurait dit un
peu plus chaque jour je m'habille c'est
mon père pour parler d'amour comme ça
l'était fallait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je croyais moi t'aimer jusqu'à la nuit
des temps je croyais à notre amour pur
et dur et longtemps mais je sais
qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai au fond de moi
que chaque grille ennuis dès que je
tapais reçoit attendre ayant mis un
soubassement s'accroche pire - de
chagrin qui lie la drache et ne restent
pas là là me regarde écrire pas que moi
que les pyrénées ne me reproche pas nous
associer notre folie quand je parle du
parc jambes de ta vie
[Musique]
je croyais et mais jusqu'à son dernier
jour du croyait que ton chagrin allait
durer de toujours mais je sais que
demain notre amour viendra rendre à la
main il emmènera alors publiera tous nos
chers souvenirs qui te parler de moi et
deux
tu reverras le printemps pourrait rater
d'un temps à nouveau les serments il
passera le temps il lui dira un jour au
lieu de montre à la fois un train
dernier amour que le diable temps parce
que le diable t'emporter le diable temps
partiel
[Applaudissements]
en ce temps là
nous n'avions pas un show
[Musique]
ici
c
je me sens
alors
et
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tum habilité
commun
[Applaudissements]
c'est parfait
je t'aime
c'est parti
non
[Musique]
ça
comme ça
bien
[Musique]
ne pas oublier
après temps de jeu
là
[Musique]
à
ça
bien
la meneuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
revient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hop
ban
j'avais dessiné
[Musique]
sur le sable
son beau visage
qui souriaient
[Musique]
puis il appelait
sur cette plage
[Applaudissements]
dans cet orage
elle a disparu
[Musique]
et j'écris
à lune
[Musique]
qu'elle revienne
et je pleurais
[Musique]
je me suis assis
rennes ce soir
et la belle dame
c'était en fait
[Musique]
je les cherche pas
ce au plus y croire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour guider
et
rien
allez
la mienne
et je pleurais
j'avais trop de peine et l'écrire
il y a
la lune
à vienne
jamais mon open
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suzuka petrik c'est un jeune il faut
bien de réflexion
ça que tu m'expliques un peu
comment te dire adieu
mon coeur de silex
[Musique]
perez
je ne
les u11 à tulle
je sais bien calé
et
on n'a pas de chien
mais aussi
mais pour
[Musique]
sous aucun prétexte
je ne
il toi sur x
ils sont
[Musique]
chausson
je dirais que
[Musique]
comment côté radio
et
tu es mise à l'eau
leblanc
pour
question
sous quel prétexte
non bien sûr m
il est clean
je suis
2 non tu te diras tu
[Musique]
il
nous te dira tout
[Musique]
gratuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dire adieu
je
[Musique]
puisque l'amour s'en va
ap
m
bienvenue
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
oh
[Musique]
de fait les deux
comme si c'était hier
d'accord vous
ou est-ce que la mousson
[Musique]
pardonner
leye
tout ce petit monde
partager
de ce billet
[Musique]
ça
les temps
à
non
[Musique]
oui
bah
comme si c'était
whissell
à
vous
un coup
adieu
[Musique]
ce
que c'est
oui
c'est lui
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
encore
[Musique]
es salaam où s'en va
puisque la mousse
oui cela
[Musique]
adieu
mais matin se suivent et se ressemblent
[Musique]
en fait place au quotidien
c'est pas fait pour vous ensemble
ça ne suffit pas
toujours de seine
c'est drôle y est l'on s'ennuyait
et cet appel si l'on pouvait même source
parle du monde attends le
le
et me donne puis nous
en un sens les choses a dit qu'ils
tiennent trop ok
le sup ii
[Musique]
c'est fait
et comment ce qu'ils font
[Applaudissements]
tout simplement sans penser à
à
[Musique]
si bien du jour 1
adieu
ça se passe à pretoria m
[Musique]
tous fait ce qu'il faut
tiens non
[Musique]
on se regarde
fillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que jean nous sommes
c'est pas facile
je se dit
et l'on sait trop mai
ça
ce soir
d'airbus
[Musique]
de ce roman
n'a jamais
va se paie conte de fées
maison passer là
[Musique]
on cherche
et quand ce qui
sympa on s'en passera
à
demain qui vient toujours
c'est pas simple combien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
julien
les autres
[Musique]
ils ont fait
une simple histoire
le seul
on écrira
à l'entrée
mais c'est ici
va descendre ensemble si tu veux
et quand
à c
mon papa temps
tu caf
le salut est amour je
c'est
ce qui
le ca
on sera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui vient
[Musique]
le français passe un peu trop
donc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu te dire que je m'en vais
[Musique]
et hélas
je
dix civils bien
je suis venu te d
souvient de vos insultes
têtu
je suis faut que tu publies
plein de raisons
des adieux j'aime
je suis regrette
tu te dis
oui je vais
je
te dis
le jeu
des sanglots longs
si bien
mais
je suis venu te d
tu te souviens des jeux anciens
étude le
il
du sang rouleau tu t'es tu me
quelle semaine
des adieux
je suis
deux bières
[Musique]
car
je suis venu te dire
je vends
[Musique]
je
comme dit si bien
je suis venu te dire
tu te souviens des choses en sus
et tu peux
[Musique]
tu sues faut que tu es
jésus
[Musique]
je suis au
tout jeu
je suis veut jeudi
des sanglots longs
je
je sais bien
[Musique]
je suis venu
souvient des jours heureux des tumeurs
tu sembles du tout
des adieux
et
je suis au regret
je te dire
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
j'avais deux jours
dans son porte-monnaie
île aux trésors
et des pièces de francs usées
la soude quad marc pour mettre des
rideaux ou bleu aux fenêtres de ses yeux
aux fenêtres ses yeux
un livre à la main sur le balcon
elles s'endormaient dans un vieux
fauteuil de manille je cherchais des
prénoms mas dieu ceci
en regardant
dix hommes
dans l'école des filles et des garçons
causse noir
moi ça
moussa dites moi dites moi même
[Musique]
les
palois
qui tournoient ça
or
e
il n'ya que très mal
quel à prismes
d'abandonner
[Musique]
où est la force mais qu'est ce qui m'a
pris j'ai brisé
[Musique]
et j'entends m
triki
rien n'est de notre lit
mais dites moi
des droits
mais pour un autre que
à
voir
dites moi ça
quatre mois
et nous
paris pour un autre devoir
à cause de moi
tu t'en sors
moi
[Musique]
demar pas à cause de moi
et tout ça
moi lui
[Musique]
et pan
course 2 mois
dites moi ça
dit
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
koné la glace a fait part en temps de
faire le nécessaire
bon
[Musique]
retourner ça me fait drôle divorcer mais
ça fait rien
si tu voyais mon avocat ce qu'il veut me
faire dire de toi il ne trouve pas d'
excuses
non mais
jose 2
fallait que je les oublie
[Musique]
je t'accuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gardera pas
g serait de temps
[Musique]
ces jours là
j'ai tant rêvé
dessous
sinon que de quoi que ce soit
en attendant
je suis le temps sortir tu veux
tu te jeter
[Musique]
les juges
vim
[Musique]
et tous
c'est maintenant
c'est passé mais au début
je vais presque
évidemment
des jaloux
mon orgueil on
je refusais
[Musique]
à présent ça va beaucoup mieux
et finalement je suis et
lazuli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fait aussi
[Musique]
veilleux pour
6e
je
[Musique]
le vix
certes un bon score
[Musique]
entre
[Applaudissements]
et
ce serait moche dans la
toi et moi à se détester
[Applaudissements]
il fait
[Musique]
pour m
car cette fois ci c'est pour de bon
c'est parti vous
m
regardez moi bien dans les yeux et jure
moi ce sera mieux
[Musique]
seul
c'est fichu
[Musique]
levitt
tous
[Musique]